knowing where people are coming from is
one of the best ways to understand where
they are so asking questions about
people's experiences that led to their
views and asking questions about the
concerns people have around their issues
are great ways to
not be so judgmental so that you can be
curious when you're curious you actually
cannot be judgmental these are two
different modes um so pushing us away
from judgment back into curiosity back
into curiosity back into curiosity does
amazing things for our relationships
[Music]
[Music]
this week on forward very happy to
welcome to the podcast monica guzman the
author of i never thought of it that way
how to have fearlessly curious
conversations and dangerously divided
times and the chief storyteller for one
of my favorite organizations in all the
world braver angels welcome monica how
are you hey hey i am doing great it's
good to be here you are on the road on
your book tour is that right that's
right yep we're heading into the third
month uh and and heading all over the
place we're gonna dig into to your your
book um but let's give people a preface
first how your book
uh tour has been going so far and what
the heck's it about the book tour has
been going great it's new york dc
sacramento florida universities virtual
and actual events i love being able to
go places in person that's been really
important because people want to share
their stories about
how divided the country is how it's
affecting them and
they they want to feel like there's hope
and there is
and my book is is partly about that it's
called i never thought of it that way
because
when we think or say i never thought of
it that way it's a sign that some
insight has landed with us
because we've been exploring something a
little bit different and it feels like
more i never thought of it that way
moments
is kind of what the coal country needs
amen uh to that uh it does evince a
level of humility you know what i mean
because if you say i never thought of it
that way then it's that oh i'm
open-minded i'm learning something new
i'm not fixed
in my ideas so a lot of this
is born of your personal experience as a
lot of things are
where
you immigrated to this country from
mexico uh when you were six you are i
suppose you'd consider yourself fairly
uh left-leaning or
or liberal but your parents were avid
trump voters and supporters which is an
experience that i think at least some
people can relate to um i will say that
i have family members uh who voted for
trump you've navigated that experience
and seemed more successfully than many
that's one way to put it
yeah
yeah yeah i mean you you like continued
uh
obviously um you know conversations with
them and and more um whereas i know some
folks have unfortunately
uh like avoided family that sort of
thing which i i have to say seems like a
thousand percent the wrong approach yeah
and it's it's a thousand percent an
understandable approach considering
the anxiety that pervades everything
these days when we're more scared more
stressed more anxious
we don't want to challenge ourselves
more you know we want to make things
streamlined and so we do what we see is
happening which is we
sort ourselves to be even closer to
people who are like us and then we other
the people who are different that's
that's a reaction to so much of the fear
and suspicion that's going on and it's
also understandable because hey these
are in some cases meaningful
relationships people have and there's a
lot of pain in trying to square
someone you love or treasure with an
idea you think they hold that is to you
abominable so i get it
but at the same time to your point
i think there is so much more harm
being done
by in in the not attempting in in the in
the burning the bridges
instead of just leaving them there you
don't have to cross them today
you don't have to cross them tomorrow
but leave the relationships intact so
that there is a chance
that you can communicate across them it
doesn't have to be now but at least it
can still happen
i think your personal
arc is fascinating so you grew up
primarily in new hampshire which is a
state i know well from uh when i
campaigned you spent a lot of time in
new england which i've also spent time
in and it's like uh you know like
frankly it's like
not that diverse
the place is
which by the way i'm like you know it's
like i'm not knocking it i'm just you
know just his numbers uh you must have
had your own personal experiences uh
with race and i guess i'll all open
uh just talking like i'm um son of
immigrants grew up in a town that was
predominantly white
uh very proud of
my my heritage uh but also think that
you know there there are a lot of things
that unite americans uh from different
backgrounds and that uh like defining
ourselves uh solely by
uh race is not a recipe for a successful
uh democracy or civil society i don't
know if you had had any sort of similar
experiences uh yourself after i was six
years old and moved to new england i was
in a almost entirely white town in new
hampshire uh dover new hampshire i went
to a catholic school i was catholic
myself
uh but but as a sign of you know
diversity comes in many forms
throughout an embarrassingly large chunk
of elementary school
i thought everyone was catholic
i didn't know that there was christian
that wasn't catholic
for a really long time because it was an
irish catholic town so even though i was
latina and i spoke spanish and i had
these different things in my heritage i
also shared a lot you know this religion
with the people i grew up around that
was very different from from other
places so that's just one example
it was it was an interesting experience
for me i i remember uh the principal
sister monica when i first got to the
school
couldn't believe that i could count to a
hundred in english and in spanish and i
think i was in kindergarten at the time
so she literally paraded me around this
small catholic school all the way up to
the eighth grade classrooms just to show
me off so i
i had the experience of seeing my
difference as something very special in
that community it wasn't threatening it
was novel
and so that was my experience of my
cultural difference the other thing is
it was actually kind of a perk to be the
only like hispanics for a while in this
town at least you know for the most part
uh we would go to restaurants and uh
we'll talk about me and my parents in
our relationship i'm sure but we had
loud debates about anything and i'm
convinced that we could we could speak
more loudly than most people could get
away with because nobody understood what
we were saying
oh you're just going rapid fire spanish
i mean sure sure it was just background
noise to everybody else so
so we turned the volume way up on our
all our political debates growing up
wow you started them way back then
you then went to college not that far
from there in maine in bowdoin then you
did some more time in new england as a
fellow at harvard uh but it seems like
you really made your remark uh as a
journalist in seattle where you started
this uh sort of unifying newsletter plus
community events plus uh
ways to get to know your
neighbors and and get engaged in new
ways which sounds phenomenal
you seem like someone who
naturally rejoices in bringing people
together and like right now you
professionally bring people together
which i'm going to suggest is a very
important role in american life today i
i
imagine myself trying to do the same
thing probably not as successfully as
you
i mean i
it's been awesome to
to to feel that bridge building is a
thing
and that many people are doing it you're
doing it in your way i'm doing it in
mine and we're starting to understand
just how critical of a role that is but
in seattle
i have been a journalist my whole career
and there were so many ways that it felt
like
journalism organizations were sort of
castles in the sky
making decisions about what people ought
to care about but without necessarily
staying plugged into the actual
communities they were serving all the
time journalism is going through a
fascinating and really wonderful
reckoning around this so we've talked a
lot on the podcast how
thousands of local papers have gone out
of business tens of thousands of
journalists have lost their jobs
uh so this reckoning is painful the
local news deserts in many communities i
think are one of the forces that are
polarizing us and making democracy less
and less uh successful uh
so i'm a big believer in local
journalism and
it's awesome to me that you lived that
for years and then just decided to try
and do it a better way and it was
lovely because what i set out to show is
that it's possible
to
start at a small scale make sure you're
connected really well to people and
talking to people and then grow from
there in media the whole thing is about
scale and you get to scale and then you
worry about how well you're connected
and and instead i wanted to reverse that
model and say no we're going to start
with connection right at the beginning
and uh and it was amazing the kinds of
participation rates we had when we asked
people questions the number of stories
that we did that were a result of asking
people what are your deep down honest
questions about homelessness and we
partnered with other newsrooms in the
city we got 400 questions and each of
those taught us something about the
fault lines in our community that we
could then do our reporting to solve so
it was everything starting with people
the alpha the omega everything has to
connect with people or else what are you
doing how do you know it's relevant how
do you know it's helping us
so i want to retrace your steps a little
bit um high school college were you
always this
positive and unifying and uh
like the hub of a community were you the
sort of person that was always
organizing
uh concerts and get togethers or that
sort of thing
i was shy as heck as a kid
just so i remember that
i think i even wrote in the book this
terrifying moment where my mother we
were sitting at a burger king and she
just made me go up and ask for a packet
of salt
and i didn't
want to approach another human being
i was just too scared
but i think that what
ended up
changing me i suppose is that at some
point my curiosity about people just
overtook me and it i was more afraid of
not knowing something about that
fascinating person than i was about
approaching them and asking questions
and then everything just kind of went
from there and i thought people are so
darn cool they're always so fascinating
and interesting
why aren't we working together what's
going on this is weird
this isn't helping us and and i have to
say someone like you thinking they're
awesome tends to lead them to be more
awesome that's one of like the
secrets to humanity
i mean it was i think that's true it was
um my favorite thing about journalism
early on
you know lots of journalists have
different reasons they love what they do
mine was
disappearing into someone else's story i
mean every now and then i'd have these
like moments where i'm in the middle of
an interview it's
really cool to hear about what someone's
passionate about what they care about
why they work on what they work and and
i just realized i'm almost like outside
myself just
happily serving as a as a channel for
this person to discover themselves and
then for me to have the honor of being
able to tell that story to their
community hopefully as responsibly as
possible so that that story can inspire
can inform can challenge but make sure
that everybody understands what's up so
at what point did you
discover this talent or knack of yours
for helping other people tell their
stories um because now you are the chief
storyteller at this incredible unifying
organization
were you uh uh like did you run the
college paper
was it that was that kind of thing yeah
i think it was the
the summer after my freshman year of
college i did an unpaid internship at
new hampshire public radio i remember
once i was interviewing the governor and
i forgot to turn on my mic i was
terrible at the technology i was also
very nervous i was still getting over my
shyness but there was one night where i
was sitting outside of an independent
movie theater that was a remodeled
church
and i decided i wanted to do a feature
story about independent cinemas my big
fat greek wedding was out then do you
remember like the independent cinema
renaissance so i was sitting outside
that theater with the theater's owner
and he had created this theater as an
incredible community hub it was in a
small town
and people loved it and so i just i
wanted to know why and how
and i'm sitting there talking to him and
that's when i realized
this is so cool
and and i remember looking at him and he
was just kind of looking away
and again sort of discovering why what
he did
was so interesting and getting into his
own story and i thought this is
this is this is what i want to do i want
to have these kinds of conversations
that that sort of help people understand
what they bring and what they already
are
uh
yeah that's where it sort of began it
was almost an addiction after that point
and i thought i got to make sure that i
keep doing this one way or another
life can be overwhelming we all know
this
often we burn out without even realizing
it that could end up being lack of
motivation or irritability or fatigue or
just shortness things like that and i
want to talk to you guys about better
help because it is a type of online
therapy that wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself and helps you just
kind of work through your thoughts
personally i use better help use it a
lot during covid i called it my steam
valve just to blow off some steam just
to collect my thoughts talk about things
i don't necessarily want to talk about
publicly
with someone online securely privately
personally so better help if you don't
know is a customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera even
if you don't want to it's private secure
it's convenient easy to schedule it's
awesome it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours so
really really easy to start so listen
our listeners of forward podcast are
going to get 10 off their first month
that's betterhelp.com
yang so check it out that's
betterhelp.com
yang take care of your head guys check
it out right now betterhelp.com
[Music]
so when you started the
new journalism project that was a hybrid
community newsletter events in seattle
uh how did you get the resources to do
that or was that like a pure bootstrap
type thing so we partnered with whereby
us which is a media startup
out of miami with extraordinarily
intelligent people they had this
human-centered design approach that i
had heard about because i was a tech
journalist in seattle for many years and
i knew it worked and it was very
iterative and creative and we got to
apply it
to even the process of researching what
the publication should be it was called
the ever gray it and it's still around
by the way it's doing great but we asked
people questions like
you know let's say it's a year from now
and you want to get the heck out of
seattle
what had to happen
for you to feel that way and then the
the the opposite question let's imagine
it's a year from now and you've never
loved seattle more you've never felt
more connected to the city what had to
happen for for that to be the reality
and with questions like that before we
even created the publication we were
able to kind of make a make a map of
what does it mean for people to build
meaningful local lives
and that was really the driving question
what does it mean for people to have
meaningful lives rooted where they are
because we knew that the more connected
people are to their city and to each
other in their city the better that city
is going to be the more investment
people are going to put into
whatever institutions or whatever
structures you know the neighborhood dog
walk it doesn't matter it doesn't have
to be you go to city hall it can be i'm
in a book club anything that connects
you locally
is going to help you get more invested
in making it a better place to be
oh yeah i love the fact that people can
just do things on their own because if
you wait for city hall or whatnot to get
itself together you know you might be
waiting for a while been waiting for a
while
so you
won awards at the ever gray how did you
wind up connecting to braver angels like
what was that process like yeah so that
was june or july of 2019 there was a
conference in dc called the weave summit
uh connected with the aspen institute
and david brooks at the new york times
and so i went because they invited uh
and paid for all these bridge builders
from around the country to come and
share best practices and talk about what
we do so wholesome it was
it was really cool
like the bridge builder summit but uh it
was there that i saw john wood jr speak
and i know that you've had him on the
show he's the national ambassador for
bravery angels and he gave
he gave the most nuanced
talk about race and division that i had
ever heard
and then after a break in the conference
there were these brochures put on
everybody's chairs and it was her braver
angels and i just picked it up and went
what
i thought this was impossible someone
already did it i was doing this work
that was my reaction to when i found out
like was he curious
so of course i just went john hi i'm
monica hey what's up you know and i'd
spoken at the conference too and he's
like i love what you had to say i was
like i don't know what you have to say
and it just went from there ended up
volunteering for a number of months and
then while i was writing my book i was
able to join the staff and
i mean you're probably like i was home
for angels i actually thought that your
book sprang from braver angels
yeah it almost seems to right because
well this is the great thing about
bridge building is from all these
different directions and experiences a
lot of people are discovering the exact
same principles
about how people work
right as a way as a road map out of this
mess we're in
and uh yeah but like the bulk of the
book was all there before i joined
braver angels wow it's really a match
made in heaven so for people who don't
know about braver angels uh it's an
organization that's meant to heal
cross-partisan divides it was started
in ohio i believe in the midwest where
they'd
brought
maybe a dozen avid trumpers and a dozen
avid democrats together and tried to get
them to find their common humanity quite
successfully i'm happy to say and then
it turned into a bus tour and now it's
like a million dollar plus organization
with uh thousands of donors who are
trying to
uh knit us back together
uh so was that a reasonable uh
description i mean hopefully john will
yell at me if that wasn't very good
because uh you know like you said
quite like john
but but yeah and we have 50 000
subscribers we have 74 local chapters
across the country i'm actually 30
minutes away
from south lebanon ohio which was the
site of that very first workshop uh
right after the 2016 election that
started everything so later today i'm
gonna go check it out because i've never
been there so yeah how did you
become so passionate about trying to
have curious conversation i mean you're
naturally curious person seems to be a
driving theme in your career um uh but
your book what i love about it is that
it actually is practical um it's born of
the you know the experience you've had
getting
hundreds maybe thousands of people to
open up yeah that was definitely a goal
from the beginning uh i had
read a lot about
why we're here how we got here it's a
really interesting problem and we
haven't solved it the first part of my
book is called sos it's the call for
help
sorting othering siloing those are the
three forces that brought us here
yeah i mean it's a it's a real
you know
but the other four fifths of the book
uh walk people through this path where
first we understand curiosity and how it
works in our brains when we when we pay
attention to the gap between what we
know and what we don't know it's this
incredible craving that can get us to do
so much and so you can actually turn it
on you don't have to wait for it to come
up you can turn it on and channel it and
target right the things you don't
understand and then we learn the power
of conversation especially a one-to-one
conversation it's people are you know
scared of them in some ways because they
are so unpredictable and so powerful
that it doesn't even matter almost who
you are outside the conversation in that
conversation you can have this
extraordinary ability to cut through any
divide if you if you know how to ask
perceptive and powerful questions if you
know how to stay respectful and build
traction with each other and then you
know the book goes on through a series
of solutions or you know things to try
that are based um around a couple of
core ideas and i'll mention one of them
now which is that knowing where people
are coming from is one of the best ways
to understand where they are so asking
questions about people's experiences
that led to their views and asking
questions about the concerns people have
around their issues are great ways to
not be so judgmental so that you can be
curious when you're curious you actually
cannot be judgmental these are two
different modes um so pushing us away
from judgment back into curiosity back
into curiosity back into curiosity does
amazing things for our relationships
people you know i've learned as a
journalist people love to talk about
themselves oh yeah if it's if it's in a
generous context they want to tell their
story who doesn't want to be heard
yeah most of us love to hear ourselves
talk because
we're very wise uh we have a lot to
offer we think we are well you know what
but but no that's the serious point is
you know we live in a society that that
sort of still thinks well you know
you're only as wise as your education
you're only as wise as your intelligence
you know you're only as wise as these
things and we don't we don't think about
wisdom all that much
we all have life we all are experts in
life and we have walked our own paths
through it and everybody's path is
interesting
no matter what you conclude if you
believe a bunch of baloney your path
still contains a lot of truth
and so it's those things that we need to
mine
and and and look behind
you know all those places that we feel
we're stuck look behind that to the
person's path to their story and you'll
you'll discover pretty interesting stuff
that'll help you relate and connect not
agree that's not that's not the point
but relate and connect so that we can
do stuff together
yeah live together live together
want to talk to you guys about a new
sponsor we have called air table and if
you've ever tried to do any sort of
leadership activity or startup you have
seen airtable at least be offered to you
as an awesome solution in this ever
changing landscape of work how can you
ensure your people workflows and data
stay connected airtable is how airtable
allows you to create flexible systems
that help your team operate as one i've
used it a few times different orgs and
it's fantastic so break down the
barriers that leave teams feeling
disconnected with airtable your team
works from a single source of truth that
is always up to date and keeps everyone
on the same page so with their adaptable
approach everyone from marketers to
product teams to podcast producers can
build tools that fit uniquely to the way
they work plus airtable keeps individual
projects connected to your higher level
goals so you never lose sight of what
you're working toward it's pretty
awesome so give it a try for free at
airtable.com today that's airtable.com
to get started for free check it out
guys a massively helpful tool
[Music]
now we're at this tough juncture in
american life where we need to try and
knit
uh democracy and our communities back
together uh which is painstakingly
difficult to do one-to-one now what is
the size of a typical braver angels
session or workshop of which i'm sure
you've attended at this point dozens
yeah i mean they can range depending on
the workshop as you might expect um but
our famous red blue workshop is eight
reds eight blues and then moderators to
walk them through the structure
that
helps them
understand each other practice humility
in front of each other which builds
trust it's an extraordinary workshop
it's been you know studied by academics
it's been proven to be depolarized by
like a marriage uh oh yeah bill
daugherty who i just saw the other night
and did an event with him in minnesota
he is really really quite brilliant and
has a lot of years in marriage marriage
and family therapy where you you learn
america needs family therapy yeah
well you know but the difference with
america is you know
300 million
right well well that's the conundrum
right because with america we don't want
to think of divorce as an option
it's not an option and some people think
it is it's it can't be right i mean that
that's that's what i think like faith in
this project is ultimately about divorce
is not an option so we have to contend
with each other uh so his strategies
inform all the all the workshops that
brave angels does um skills to bridge
the divide families divided by politics
the red blue workshop depolarizing
within uh we started a skills for social
media workshop and launched it in the
fall it's been really successful it's a
great e-course wait wait no no i have a
summary skills for social media
turn it off
yeah
what do you think
you know i think that was one of the
reasons that it sort of took a little
while to get to that workshop it's just
like well you know these these are not
great spaces to have these kinds of
conversations in the book i talk about
five conditions for constructive
conversations across the divide and one
of the most important is containment to
what degree is a conversation contained
to the people participating in it the
the less contained a conversation is the
less candid i i'm going to turn around
and broadcast this conversation to
thousands tens of thousands of people
monica
yeah no i know you are i know yeah but
somehow you know what podcasts are worse
are worth thinking about because this
conversation is a powerful one-to-one
conversation and the internet can't just
as easily like take little quotes out of
context from podcasts we all know that
podcasts allow us to be more candid
because it's harder to chop into bits
that lose the message that lose the
power
that's why podcasts are becoming so much
more popular because people know that
there's some kind of candor and truth
that is coming out in podcasts that
you're just not going to experience
anywhere else
at least in a public way and that has a
lot to teach us the contain thing is
very important because you know what is
what is like the
temptation now in american life is just
to turn around and say hey i had this
conversation with this person and then
put it on social media and it elevates
you particularly absolutely
yeah yeah like i can't tell you how many
times uh when i was running for
the mayor in particular someone would
like run up to me with a cell phone just
trying to like you know provoke or do
something and like it really does you're
like oh my gosh like it's a very
antagonistic act to just like run up to
someone
with like a vote yeah when you have a
conversation with someone your
expectation is like hey we're going to
talk like humans and then right
like and if i were to say something
um like imperfect you wouldn't just turn
around and be like oh this person said
it said excellent right it is a very
important principle you kind of take for
granted um in normal life but now today
like it's hard to take that for granted
oh absolutely i mean we've built these
we've built these structures on social
media where you get a lot of points
right you get a lot of points for
sharing some new outrage i mean we know
this and so that's just become oh it's
actually yeah like infiltrated our
normal way of communicating with each
other i get particularly sad when i see
you know
a neighbor you know there's something
that happened in everett washington some
years ago and i'll
you know float over the details but
basically a neighbor went into a bakery
in in her town and saw a cookie that had
some kind of message on it that really
offended her and so what she chose to do
was to put that on social media and talk
about how awful it is and how awful the
baker the bakery was
but think about what would have happened
if the first thing that woman had done
was talk to the baker yeah talk to the
baker talk to your neighbor first and
you you don't know i mean it could have
it became as you can imagine this viral
national story i mean we've seen this
over and over so that's what it is when
we talk about remitting ourselves
together it's like why why go to the
massive strangers before you go to your
neighbor
why not talk to you the social media
version of this i will share with you
monica
it's like someone that i'm connected to
where we've dm'd with each other will
like say something on social media and
i'm like dude you could've just dm to me
exactly
you know and in the case of someone like
you i can kind of understand people
being like well super hard to reach you
know probably hears a lot of people but
even then it's like you gotta you gotta
try
one thing that you can't witness on
social media is the act of people
listening so some people are listening
like yes you know and and judgments and
resentments are building but you have
you don't know they didn't hit like on
your post they didn't comment on it you
have no idea and that's what we're doing
it's like all these built-up resentment
you know have you ever been on been on
social media and you scroll through and
then you stop and you go back to your
thing and suddenly you're more stressed
out and this has happened to me so many
times like social media has a negative
effect on your
mind you know eight or nine carry that
with you yeah so anyway back to your
point about well maybe the maybe the
social media skills workshop just
doesn't get on social media but but
that's not realistic because we know all
the good that comes out of it right we
know that we have to play ball in there
my friend angel eduardo says social
media is the boss level of discourse it
is so much more difficult because
you're bringing this tiny little
carry-on
you know like of tiny little tools of
human communication well i have i have
text the occasional photo and some
emojis and i'm going to try to
you know carry my meaning about the
hardest issues in american life
it's like what
but that's why you know pick up the
phone um you know on tweet like go okay
can we dm anytime that you can you can
raise containment anytime that you can
raise uh what i call embodiment you know
the fact that you and i are talking on
zoom you can see me gesture you can hear
my tone i can hear yours
it's so much more powerful way to convey
our meaning to each other so again it's
not impossible to do these things on
social media but it takes being able to
stuff into words and emojis what we
normally need a lot more tools to be
able to convey so you said before that
divorce is not an option and i want to
to relay my
experience with this notion of like
civil war in america so traditionally
um conservatives were like oh yeah i
might have to have a civil war and it's
like a very very nasty
unwelcome thought and then people on the
left were like like of course you can't
have a you know like a civil war and
even talking about it is like alarmist
uh sensationalist uh you know
unproductive destructive actually
um and that that has flipped
a lot this past year where a number of
books have come out by respected
political scientists like barbara walter
uh how civil wars start uh stephen mars
the next civil war
um i've looked at the data and the data
suggests strongly to me that we're
heading towards some kind of
strife or conflict uh not like uh you
know secession like 13 states are going
to vote or any of that like nothing like
that but folks doing terrible things uh
in part born of what what you you know
said before about being uh otherwise and
siloed and sorted uh and the rest of it
um so i i've been making the case that
look we're heading towards something
very very nasty and negative not like a
political divorce but we're gravitating
towards
a societal divorce if you will
or
let people uh it's one reason why i
think that though the work you're doing
is so important in that i love braver
angels so much
it i don't know if you'd seen the same
switch in thinking among certain people
yeah i mean
for all the enthusiasm and positivity
right a part of me feels like i
shouldn't say well we're kind of already
in a civil war
but i think we are and i don't mean to
be alarmist i think it's important to to
think a lot of people think civil war
and think about the 1800s no you know
war changes with technology war changes
with cultures uh i studied some
political conflict you know in school
and whatever but like wars are different
and i think that right now
it's it's largely about media and
communication and in in that sense when
we have this much misperception across
divides um the trenches are there
they're not dug into the ground but
they're they're there so so people we
keep using this language if we're headed
toward what headed toward and it's like
it's sort of like we don't want to admit
well in a lot of really meaningful ways
we're already there with uh with roe v
wade you know my big concern is
wow i mean i'd love to hear your
thoughts it feels like for the first
time in modern history again i'm not a
historian so
but it feels like for the first time in
modern history we're actually going to
have a really big issue divide
some you know more red states and some
more blue states it's going to feel a
lot more if roe is overturned and and
these states you know pass these laws
that it's going to be two countries and
people are going to i mean how can you
not how could you blame someone for
wanting to pick up and move to a
different state based on their moral
take on an issue that's this
tough and misinformed personally you
know what i mean you might be right like
hey
right so i'm afraid that the
i mean here's my fear that i that's not
justified with data but i'm just going
to be honest about my fear my fear is
that there's going to be a domino effect
you know we do it with abortion well why
don't we deal with this and that and the
other thing and then before we know it
there kind of is a red america and a
blue america like for real at what point
what is the tipping point when would
that become real enough and i don't
think i don't think that violence has to
be part of of this kind of conflict for
it to feel
like we've just given up on trying to
knit back together
that's my fear
[Music]
i i've been very very
saddened by the this and
on the fa the first people i think of
are the
women who are going to want to
have that kind of choice uh who are
going to be in red states where the
these rules change uh that may not have
the ability to head to another state
and and do what they want the
pain and anguish uh you know uh i i
feels for people like that who most of
whom will never hear about or from
because they'll be
like
you know like poor
right often
uh of immigrant populations maybe you
don't speak english you know like
they're gonna be all these
these barriers
um that that stuff makes me very very
sad
it feels very sad that the country does
seem like we're
heading backwards uh not forward you
know and then you have these senators
being like hey these justices lied to me
in my office because they said they want
to do this and here we are
and then you look at that and think like
wow like there's really not a whole heck
of a lot you can rely on uh at that
point
but you know it's like okay we've just
waded through the mug
but of course when you when you stay in
that muck and you don't see the
opportunities then
you know that's where we're really
headed south you know the reason that
i'm not in a place of despair is because
i don't think that's the story you know
thanks to braver angels i've met so many
people who completely disagree with me
on a lot of issues including this one
and had amazing conversations really
deep ones private ones one-on-ones um
and one of them that i had in the fall
was actually on an episode of the braver
angels podcast
and it was two red women who are
pro-life and two blue women including
myself who are pro-choice
and it was so powerful
and we structured it so that we would
share our experiences if we were
comfortable and we would share concerns
if we were comfortable
and i didn't change my mind overall on
things but i called uh april cornfield
who's the head of braver angel's debates
and is
red red winds red and i told her hey
it's been a week or so and i just need
to tell you that i realized something
you said has actually shifted my
thinking in one way
and i told her what that was so i tell i
say all this because
you know the the battle lines are drawn
it it does feel like it's an either or
with abortion and any other tough issue
but i think that the real tragedy the
real tragedy of all this division is
that we have so much wisdom and
intelligence and competence and capacity
if you add everybody up
and then put put us through the filters
you know the institutions and
the ways in which they're a bit poisoned
right now and what you get as an output
of all that capacity you know our
capacity is 100 the output is like
three
that's the tragedy there there has to be
there's a way to negotiate here there
are ways to come up with creative
options failed by
uh our government our representative
system our institutions the media yeah
the social media like the the people
in our capacity
are much much greater
than is being shown and that's really a
tragedy i agree with you that's that's
it so so again it's like we we get to
this place thanks to the way we tend to
talk about these issues where it really
feels like there's no creative solution
there's no best way to balance the
tensions and they're never with
something like abortion it is a wicked
issue and like technically a wicked
issue is one that you can never resolve
for all time but but each era has that
opportunity to find the best balance for
now
and so you know the more divided we are
and the more that rancor sort of defines
everything and we're not even seeing
each other clearly to begin with well
our problem-solving capacity is toast so
that that's the thing to work on is like
there are better ways
to make sure that the left and the right
the pro-life and the pro-choice are
heard and that the concerns are put on
the table and that we we strive to do
the best for the stakeholders around
this issue primarily you know women
bearing children so
let's do that right but but gosh it
feels like 90 of the energy is is on the
fight and and i get it like who can
blame anyone right the fight is is so
important
but but that's it i mean it's just what
you said and and i don't blame you know
the media and the politicians
so much as a system because to me in my
experience when you pluck out a
politician when you pluck out you know a
journalist in an influential
organization none of them want this oh
no no no they're all kind of uh trapped
themselves in this exactly
and the system it's like it's uh
brain uh of market incentives call
controls us all and i you know we have
to like put a stake in its heart or you
know like uh like this is they call it a
brain you have to like put a nail in the
brain yeah like that's the war that i
want us fighting you know not like red
versus blue but red and blue versus this
the system
this the system that's controlling us
all
yeah and that's been the best lesson
from my book tour you know such as it is
and all the interviews and everything is
i've been on conservative podcasts
liberal podcasts libertarian podcast
politically homeless podcast everyone
agrees you know that there ought to be
that we're all empowered to do this and
even in a small scale that you know the
culture will change when we change our
behavior each one of us
there's a way to do that and if we just
wait for the systems to figure it out
you know this is a democracy we're all
implicated in these systems they are not
outside of us
i was at an event
years ago it was um 2018. i just started
my presidential run but no one had ever
heard of me so when i said hey i'm
running for president people would treat
me you know like i was out of my mind
anyway
there was a woman on stage who said
um why does it feel like we're just like
all heading in a direction that none of
us wants but like none of us can do
anything about it and i i think that's
the way a lot of people feel is like
that there's like this massive wave of
of forces that are you know like driving
us apart making us upset at each other
and so that the institutional filter
leaves us at like three percent of
capacity instead of you know a a hundred
and everyone's like oh like you know
and so i'm looking at it being like okay
guys look like there are a few ways out
of this thing
uh and
one of them involves breaking free of
the duopoly you know which would involve
a couple of process changes so open
primaries would be super helpful right
voting would be super helpful
multi-party system would be super
helpful so let's do that
it's been interesting monica because
you know most people if you present to
them like hey here's how we break out of
the these manacles and uh you know like
like free ourselves or whatnot they
still don't really see it most people
some people do and i'm grateful
but what it reminds me of is this quote
from upton sinclair which is uh it's
difficult to make a man understand
something when his salary depends upon
his not understanding it right yes yes i
love that quote i love that quote yeah
that that is like a reasonable summary
of american life today is that like
there are all these people that are
part of the system getting paid by the
system and then you're like hey you hate
the system system sucks like how about
we change it
what you're talking about there is
empowerment it's it's helplessness it's
learned helplessness it's resignation
it's this idea that yeah we're in a
democracy but all we can really do is
vote every four years we only get two
choices for president really and
you know and that's that that's that's
where we're at and and this
disempowerment i think is the ultimate
monster um and what i've learned you
know through practicing in local
communities is again you can build that
sense of
direct connection uh right from the from
from a small scale and build it up up up
up and you get more powerful communities
that way uh like what we did at the
evergreen part of it is language too
you've heard me say neighbor neighbor
neighbor neighbor uh one of the things
we did at the evergreen was always talk
about people as our neighbors we never
did the us versus them for example with
homelessness often in the media it's
it's it's sort of this language where
it's like well it's us and it's the
homeless what what what you know our
homeless neighbors our neighbors
they're neighbors we're all we're all in
this together right like we we
interviewed people who were homeless not
as the object of the problem
but agents in the community
so
there's something about that too is you
actually have to
work hard and go outside a lot of
conventions to make people feel their
own power
you know in their own role that they
play and it's it's easier to do it
locally why because of embodiment people
can actually get together and shake each
other's hands and see each other
you know look at each other's eyes and
not hate up close on a national level
level it's almost impossible to build on
a national level without doing local
first so this brings us back back full
circle right local journalism has
suffered tanked tremendously and imagine
imagine a kind of investment and i don't
put this all on local journalism local
community building local engagement um i
just think you have to build those
levels first as a foundation right and
then get to national and pay attention
to the whole stack but again many of us
just kind of skip that step by going
here you know we go to the national
media outlets who have the resources
like tens of billions of dollars spent
on the here and then the local community
is spending exactly now and so it's like
yeah exactly by the way the production
values are much better here like
this like the talent level they'll
cherry pick one of like the best
message deliverers in in the the country
and then have them and you know deck
them out and make up and put a nice
studio behind them and like have them
you know make me feel a certain way it's
like that i know but you know what but
local can win local does win because it
has the advantage of proximity
and that and of relationship building
and trust building that that's i mean we
talk about the lack of trust you know
without trust we can't we can't have a
collective search for truth you know we
talk about a lack of shared reality
everyone believes different things we're
not going to be able to build a shared
reality until we have trust and trust is
built a lot faster and more easily on
the ground where we have all the tools
you know in our box so anyway i still
i still am optimistic because i see the
path well you're naturally a very
optimistic person but the reason why
you're optimistic and the reason why i
actually remain optimistic at least day
to day is because we're actually doing
something about it
it feels good right like
as soon as you're doing something about
it like i feel better about this because
you know
good things happen if you're not doing
anything about it then it's it's very
very difficult to you know be like oh
it'll be great
yeah let's just forget about it it's
making me sad no i know i know and it's
not just you know doing something about
it it's also looking around and
realizing that there really are a lot of
people doing something about this you
know
and and i think i i know it's moving the
needle
so
we we can't let this conversation end
without talking about family a bit do
you have a family of your own now yes
two kids nine and seven wow me too same
ages nine and six two boys no way so
your parents must now be very happy that
uh their their grandparents and all that
jazz um so they have no choice but uh
oh they love it they love it but you you
talked about how you've had political
disagreements uh with them for for a
long time uh go ahead and
give guidance to folks who might have a
similar situation uh in their family
where they feel like there's this
uh political divide yeah and this is
where you know my my inbox has become
like a
a confession booth you know a place
where a lot of people are telling me
about these stories with family where
there's such strong relationships one
story i can think of that i shared with
braver angels is a woman named courtney
who's very purple herself doesn't
consider herself red or blue but cares
deeply about some political issues and
loves her father dearly and and there
was a moment where they fought so hard
about politics that her father said
that's it we just can't talk about
politics anymore no no
and so
i mean that seemed like okay for maybe a
bit but what courtney realized and i
think a lot of people realize
is that when
when when you care deeply about certain
issues and and you know you're very
concerned about them um then it feels
like when you can't talk about politics
you can't even be yourself and the
people you love can't know you or see
you
and and that's the thing that we can't
that's no way to live in a way right
like if we have these meaningful
relationships what gives them meaning is
that we can be our full selves around
each other so that's the conundrum for a
lot of people the solution is well we
just don't talk about politics and maybe
that's fine you know if it's just
thanksgiving dinners and here and there
and you keep that bridge open that's
fine but in times like this when is
there so much more heat and stress you
want to be able to do something about it
so among the
the most powerful i think things that
you can try is we tend to want to engage
with each other on the level of
logic and syllogism and reason right why
do you believe what you believe how
could you possibly believe what you
believe ah you know but even if you take
the
disrespectful tone out and you leave why
do you believe what you believe even
then we think of why it's such a
powerfully curious question but in times
of division and suspicion
why
puts people on the defensive it it makes
them reach for uh what's the talking
point what's the thing that oh gosh i
better show up well to this relative of
mine or they're gonna think less of me
or here we go i'm being put to the test
it's like you're on trial
we're putting each other on trial when
we ask why and everyone has to think of
their reason
and and they won't think of candid
reasons usually you know they'll just go
for what feels safe because so many
people are not even comfortable sharing
their political beliefs so instead
ask questions around how
how did you come to believe what you
believe
you know what comes up for you like
so dad i know that you and i disagree
hugely about immigration and i'm i'm
really curious like
what
what kind of things have happened you
know in your life that that make you
make you think that your position on
this is is really important and ask it
that way and
and what happens is that the questions
naturally carry a lot less judgment and
what you're doing is you're collecting
sort of knowledge about that person's
path that person's experience how did
you come to this mistake in an opinion
now i'm kidding right well that's the
thing you got to peel off the disrespect
keep them cured people think that every
question is curious like journalists
know better right some questions are
just accusations disguised as questions
they're just gotcha they're meant to
disqualify people i think i've never
been on the receiving end of some of
them i i know that you have
you know and sometimes it's in the
public good because it's a powerful
person blah blah blah we know that but
with each other on a one-to-one
relationship level if we're trying to
build trust
you know if we're trying to build trust
then we have to accept we have to accept
each other first
which is the radical thing and then
understand each other
and then judge i mean what we're doing
is we're judging recklessly because we
don't even see
we're not even seeing each other clearly
so when we judge what are we judging
we're judging projections we're judging
ghosts
you know that's no way to build a
society so we have to fix that we have
to get each other's stories and have
them and invite people to take us on a
tour
through their path and the concerns and
the experiences that make it up uh
instead of put them on trial wow you
could really do a lot of good monica
can i can i tell there's there's a woman
who left a review of my book on amazon
it like brought me to tears but she said
that she had
not talked to her 85 year old mother who
had voted for trump for years
and that
she read the book and she thought the
tips were pretty good and so she put
them to work and she says
you know she started listening to her
mom and asking different kinds of
questions and now she says
their relationship is really good and i
i mean that made it all worth it you
know yeah that would make everything
worth it that made it all worth it i
will share with you that uh i got
dozens of times over my campaign
um like thank you you helped bring our
family together because you know like we
you helped
uh us feel like we could like agree on
something yeah and like that was like an
incredible
blessing to hear i was like wow
you know another thing that someone said
to me too is like they had a
trump supporting mom
um and they themselves were were uh blue
and then their mom said to them that
like yang is the only democrat i would
support because he doesn't feel like
he's judging us at all
um and i was like holy cow like there's
probably a very important lesson there
yeah we should and i mean she's right
like i have zero judgment on um people
based upon their political views i
actually think i understand
what's driving a lot of what what's
happening in in this country yeah you
made such an important contribution and
you're doing it every day um
but i'm going to wrap on this thought
that's been stuck in my head a little
bit i'm gonna run it by you and see see
what you think so it feels like the
republican party under trump has become
this version of sort of angry toxic
masculinity like the crazy uncle or or
grandpa
and then the democratic party has become
this um somewhat like uh you know
identity laden
moralism that like most people don't
feel is genuine and and so when you talk
about like the
country needing family of therapy like
this is an idea that's stuck with me
yeah i mean i think i think both parties
are
in this place of confusion
and and panic and a little bit of
madness because we all are
uh and that's what happens i think when
everything's a fun house mirror and
we're not sure what to do about it so
yeah the parties are just an extension
the same way that media is an extension
and politics politicians right their
behavior and the conventions all an
extension of what we're feeling on the
ground and what's going on on the ground
every time i talk with my parents so
they're they're conservative they voted
for trump twice um and i'm liberal but
as i say in the book i i've gotten to
the point where if i know that if i wore
them
i would have voted for trump too
wow
that's a very very big
and knowing that yeah like it is it's a
tough thing to admit and it took a bit
to be able to admit it in the book but
getting to the place where i could admit
that it was it was sort of well here
they are and here i am now what
it's it's not i need to defeat you i
need to change you
yes a different question it's we need to
build a society together that somehow
balances uh the different stacks of
values that we have people think people
look across the divide and say they
don't share my values but
but actually they do they just stack
them in a different order for different
issues you know when we develop
different communities different
communities develop different languages
and over time if they don't interact
that well it's a tower babble
you know and and that's what's happening
too so that's only adding to the panic
and the frustration and the madness so
we we need some of these uh you know it
counter things but again i've i've
talked to members of congress you know
one-on-one on background
people want to fix this and and i for
one am really encouraged by the work a
lot of politicians are doing um
including yourself just anyone who's
really tackling this beast instead of
just accepting the game as it is
we need that that's what we need yeah
yeah let's let's tame this beast or slay
this beast
monica
congratulations the book is awesome i
never thought of it that way how to have
fearlessly curious conversations
in dangerously divided times best of
luck in the rest of your book tour keep
bringing people together
uh and you are you really are a national
treasurer geez like you know like i feel
like if we could get you in front of
enough people we really wouldn't have a
chance at this thing i know there's hope
i know we can do it and i know we can
work together to get some real miracles
done i'm going to be a big reason why my
friend
congratulations on this
thanks andrew
[Music]
you